all right new video today and before we
get started i do want to thank the
sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by
dr squatch dr squatch is changing the
way men approach hygiene by providing
natural healthy products i've worked
with dr squash before on this channel
doing it again because right out the
gate i fell in love with their soap
feels good while you're using it in the
shower you smell great when you come out
of the shower and if you can't feel good
and smell great during and after a
shower then why are we
here well the fact they're all about
natural ingredients but their subs no
harsh chemicals good clean feeling
natural
soap doing its part to scrub off the
feeling of the past
year of the ones they gave me i feel
like they gave me their a game here i
love them all but i'm gonna go with uh
cool fresh aloe this really does smell
like a nice summer day where the hills
are alive with the sound of music so
click the link below and new customers
get 20
off their orders of 20 or more and thank
you once again to dr squatch for
sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it all right now finally
i'm going to talk about castlevania
season 4 a lot of requests i totally get
it understand if i were you i'd be
requesting too in fact
i requested this of myself i'd look in
the mirror before i went to bed and i
was like jeremy
why the [ __ ] haven't you done a video in
castlevania season four [ __ ] jeremy why
don't castlevania season four let's talk
about it so castlevania season four is
the newest
season of castlevania on netflix it's
supposedly it's gonna be the last season
i mean
technically i guess that said i'm really
satisfied with how season four thus
this series has ended and i've had a
pretty good time with the series itself
not just a pretty good time a lot of
good memories but
because i never thought i would see a
castlevania series
ever at all so i've enjoyed it some
seasons more than others i mean
let's just be real season three kind of
stands out as the one that's set up for
season four but all in all good times
also spoiler warning cause i'm gonna
talk about spoilers in this season you
know
you've been warned so season four starts
out where season three ended which is
pretty much
scifi and trevor being like okay well
you know what
we're gonna go on adventures trevor's
like we tried it your way now we're
gonna try it mine however he phrased it
starts out with a montage of them
killing demons and baddies and things
you recognize from castlevania also
someone sent a messenger to alakar
that's pretty much please help our town
so he goes to help
these refugees these people in this town
in which he runs across
san germain and the way all these plots
circle back
into each other and intertwine i thought
was really satisfying for me man i'm
jumping around but i really like
hector and isaac and their stories and
you think it's gonna go one way it
actually goes another that's what i like
about the show it surprises with the
characters but really if you
look at their characters they shouldn't
be surprises
isaac's always been effectively brutal
in the sense that he can kill people
he can dispatch folks very effectively
do so but that's not what i think of
when i think of isaac i think of
isaac the philosophical mind the deep
thinker the philosopher which is why
when hector's like all right isaac's
definitely going to kill me
isaac has all of his monsters storming
carmilla's castle i liked when isaac was
like revenge is a child's game
it's up to us to be better than children
so now i didn't see it coming but i
definitely should have but you know
it's a tv show so you don't know if it's
like okay he's philosophical and all
that but
he's still gonna do his revenge because
entertainment i was glad he didn't i was
glad he was like i think we're just
gonna be better that said i'm gonna kill
carmilla
because she's a dick i liked how
carmilla went out she was like yeah [ __ ]
you
she stakes herself like that's how she
would go out if she saw that she had no
way out she would definitely
kill herself to a not give the person
who's attacking her the satisfaction and
b
her exploding body might just take the
enemy out and hector hector's been
playing the long con or at least
making lemonade out of a lemon [ __ ]
situation while he's
basically the whipped into shape puppy
dog he he's theon greyjoy he's reek he's
playing nice and you actually get the
sense that he
and his hot vampire chick captor whose
name completely escapes me right now
they do have a thing at least from his
point of view she keeps telling carmilla
oh yeah he's a pet he's a nothing but in
terms of how she sees it could have
fooled me but he's playing nice while
he's scheming
putting little rune rocks in the cracks
in the brick meant it for his escape
uses it to help isaac out even cuts his
finger off becomes frankie four fingers
i like the conclusion that
these characters gave or these
characters got but gave us
in a world where largely season three
was the setup for that
and season three still does feel like a
setup season i was really
satisfied with the payoff here season
four the action
there was a sizable amount of it a
fulfilling amount of it it's all coming
to a head man so whether it's carmilla's
sisters none of them gearing out in her
daylight daytime armor tearing dudes up
belmont and scifi
tearing people up like scifi's op as
hell again like she always is you play
castlevania three with scifi take on
bosses dracula yeah you're gonna beat
them her magic's busted so i was always
glad that the show
showed that i also like the fact that
aldocard felt more like
alucard we got some costume upgrades
this time around alucard didn't just
have a coat like the previous seasons he
had his cape he had his shield
he also has you know when he does this
double jump well i guess
when it's not in a video game it's not
called a double jump it's just called
jumping high when he does it as cape
turns into wings like it does in
symphony of the night makes it
feel more like alucard also among the
fact that once again there's a big bad
scheme about people trying to raise
dracula
the baddie and this one all right this
is where the spoilers come in you've
already been warned by giving you one
more chance to turn away the big baddie
in season four is death which i'm glad
death makes an appearance because death
is a very important part of all the
castlevania games think of that
castlevania game think of the biggest
dick
boss battle yeah it was probably death
wasn't it right he's a
so many rage quits with death fights so
he's not actually death he's
more like a soul reaver but you know
death i will say i was bummed out that
trevor didn't
actually go out like he goes out
sacrificing himself i thought that was
great but i was like oh no he didn't
actually go out which i know
there needs to be other belmonts but
sifa was already pregnant
with his child it's one of those a big
sacrifice at the end
psych technically it was a sacrifice but
you know i guess i can come back which i
guess if scifi just
raised their kid he'd be you know a mage
like cipher so i guess he needs dad to
show him the ropes you know the way of
the whip and a compelling thing
that i think about is the fact that
dracula
and lisa they've been released you know
death's plan
fails you know death's gonna raise them
into one body
and they're just both gonna go mad and
so okay a lot of people are just gonna
get destroyed and die and death's like
i'm going to suck up all the souls you
know
like a soul reaver that falls to [ __ ]
and among all that
lisa and vlad they're they're now
released into the world and they're just
kind of
living their lives away from all this
there's a part of me that's like so
is castlevania just done forever you
know we don't get rondo we don't get
symphony of the knights of dracula is
just
okay he's fine now and that's an
interesting philosophy if not
warning that this entire series of
castlevania's had
dracula enacts this whole thing you know
to wipe out
all of humanity on earth because human
beings killed his wife and then even
after he's dead people are trying to
resurrect him like okay man
let's keep it going and he just he
doesn't he hasn't given a [ __ ] to do
that when you put
a thought out there when you speak in
anger people will run with your words
even after you don't believe them
anymore it's a form of chaos you don't
have control over
so just be warned of the bells you ring
you can't un-ring a bell the point is
i've enjoyed my time with castlevania on
netflix i thought season 4
was a great season i felt season 4 did a
good job
of it being castlevania and castlevania
to me just speaks as dracula
as the antagonist but he's not and this
was the first season where that was the
case
where i didn't actually miss dracula
season three i missed dracula i was like
man i feel that loss i feel the loss of
his presence here season
four has enough going on that is an
extension of the story of dracula
without having dracula but you still
also have death
sans remain he's kind of an extension of
the story of dracula you know so he's
lost someone he loves he wants to get
them back
and he sacrifices his soul to try to do
that and that's a satisfying way of
showing an extension of the story of
dracula without having dracula
actually in it as the antagonist in
season four
was the best season i think since one
especially for closing the book you know
the logistics are like well it's
the last season but we might have more
in the universe which could mean like
you mean you're doing other castlevania
stories with other belmonts which you
definitely should do probably should
have done by now but i'm down for that
possibility in fact
the way this ends you can bring in soma
crews
which could really blow some mines but
we'll see where it goes from here
alright so castlevania season four have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you